من جاء اولا البيضه ام الدجاجه سؤال حير
البشر منذ الاف السنين والعلماء اخيرا
يجيبون عنه
ورغم ان كثيرين كانوا ياخذون هذا التساؤل
بفكاهه الا ان علماء اخذوا القضيه على
محمل الجد واجر تجارب يجيب اخيرا عن تلك
المواضله
العلماء من المملكه المتحده والصين وجدوا
ان اسلاف الطيور والزواحف الحديثه ربما
تكون ولدت من دون البيض اصلا لافتين الى
ان بعض الانواع التي تبيض يمكن ان تكون قد
تطورت من اسلاف كانت حيه او انجبت صغارا
ويمكن ان تتحول انواع في كليهما خلال
العمليه التطوريه وتحتفظ الثدييات باجنه
داخليا فيما يعرف باسم الاحتفاظ بالجنين
الممتد ما يسمح لها بالتطور داخل الام قبل
ولادتها في سن صغيره
اذا من اتى اولا الدجاجه ان البيضه بحسب
البروفيسور مايكل بنتين من كليه علوم
الارض في بريستال الجواب الطبيعي للسؤال
الدراجه والبيضه هو انه من الواضح ان
البيضه جاءت اولا لان كل طائر يضع بيضه
وذلك منتظم الطائر الذي عاش منذ حوالي 150
مليون سنه
[موسيقى]